bem-vindo de volta a Entendendo Informação e Computação Quântica, meu nome é John Watrous e sou o diretor técnico de educação na IBM
Quantum. Esta é a lição número 14 da série e é a segunda lição da quarta unidade, que trata de erro quântico
correção. Na lição anterior, demos uma primeira olhada na correção de erros quânticos, incluindo o código Shore de nove qubits, que estabelece que
a correção de erros quânticos é possível na teoria. Também discutimos a discretização de erros, que nos permite
corrigir erros quânticos arbitrários em qubits, projetando-os efetivamente em bit flips e phase
flips. Nesta lição, vamos discutir o formalismo estabilizador, que é uma ferramenta matemática através da qual podemos
especificar e analisar uma ampla classe de códigos de correção de erros quânticos, conhecidos como códigos estabilizadores. Isso inclui o código Shore de 9 qubits
junto com muitos outros exemplos, incluindo códigos que provavelmente são muito mais adequados ao mundo real de dispositivos
de computação quântica do que o código Shore. Nem todo código de correção de erros quânticos é um código estabilizador, mas muitos são,
incluindo todos os exemplos que veremos nesta série. Certamente existem códigos de correção de erros quânticos interessantes e potencialmente úteis
que não são códigos estabilizadores, mas tendem a ser bem mais complicados e, de qualquer forma, não há
dúvida de que o formalismo estabilizador é uma pedra angular na fundação da correção de erros quânticos e nós vamos
depender muito dele pelo restante da unidade. Aqui está uma breve visão geral da lição. Vamos começar com uma curta discussão
sobre matrizes de Pauli e produtos tensoriais de matrizes de Pauli, que podem representar tanto operações em qubits quanto
medições de qubits, como vou explicar. Nesse contexto, muitas vezes nos referimos a elas como observáveis. Em seguida, vamos voltar e ter
uma segunda olhada no código de repetição e veremos como podemos descrevê-lo através de operações e observáveis de Pauli, o que vai tanto informar
quanto levar a uma discussão geral sobre códigos estabilizadores, incluindo vários exemplos, propriedades básicas dos
códigos estabilizadores e como podemos realizar as tarefas fundamentais de codificação, detecção de erros e correção desses
erros. Vamos começar a lição com uma breve discussão sobre operações de Pauli, principalmente para preparar o terreno para o
formalismo estabilizador, mas também para observar alguns fatos-chave e estabelecer uma terminologia básica. Primeiro, aqui estão as matrizes de
Pauli, incluindo a matriz identidade 2x2, bem como as três matrizes de Pauli não-identidade, que denotaremos por
X maiúsculo, Y e Z ao longo do restante da série. Todas as quatro matrizes são tanto unitárias quanto hermitianas e podemos
identificá-las com operações em um qubit, incluindo operações que podemos escolher realizar, bem como erros, como
discutimos na lição anterior. As matrizes de Pauli não-identidade X, Y e Z anticomutam entre si,
o que significa que XY é igual a -1 * YX, XZ é igual a ZX negativo e YZ é igual
a ZY negativo, e tu podes verificar facilmente essas relações fazendo as multiplicações. Essas relações de anticomutação
são muito simples, mas são criticamente importantes no formalismo estabilizador e em outros contextos, e especificamente
como veremos, esses sinais de menos que aparecem quando trocamos a ordem de duas matrizes de Pauli não-identidade diferentes num produto correspondem precisamente à
detecção de erros no formalismo estabilizador. Também temos as regras de multiplicação listadas aqui. Cada
matriz de Pauli é sua própria inversa, o que é consistente com o fato de que são tanto unitárias quanto hermitianas, e se você multiplicar quaisquer duas matrizes de Pauli não-identidade diferentes
juntas, sempre obterás mais ou menos I vezes a matriz de Pauli não-identidade restante.
Em particular, a menos de uma fase global, Y é equivalente a X vezes Z, o que explica nosso foco em erros X e Z em
correção de erros quânticos. X representa um bit flip, Z representa um phase flip, e portanto, a menos de uma fase global, Y representa
ambos esses erros ocorrendo no mesmo qubit. Essas quatro matrizes representam todas
operações, erros ou a ausência de um erro em um único qubit, mas muitas vezes é conveniente juntá-las por produto tensorial
para realizar operações ou erros em múltiplos qubits. Como ponto de terminologia, sempre que nos referirmos a uma operação de Pauli de N qubits,
queremos dizer um produto tensorial de quaisquer n matrizes de Pauli, como os exemplos mostrados
aqui. Também é comum usar o termo operação de Pauli quando há uma fase global, mas para manter as coisas o mais simples possível,
vou usar o termo operação de Pauli para significar simplesmente um produto tensorial de matrizes de Pauli. O peso de uma operação de Pauli de N qubits
é simplesmente o número de matrizes de Pauli não-identidade no produto tensorial. Por exemplo, o produto tensorial n-fold
da matriz identidade 2x2 consigo mesma é uma operação de Pauli de peso zero. Um produto tensorial de duas matrizes de Pauli X
e um monte de matrizes identidade tem peso dois, e assim por diante. Intuitivamente falando, o peso de uma operação de Pauli de N
qubits é o número de qubits sobre os quais ela age de forma não-trivial, e é típico que códigos de correção de erros quânticos sejam
projetados para que possam detectar e corrigir erros representados por operações de Pauli até um certo peso. Podemos
pensar sobre operações de Pauli de várias maneiras, incluindo como operações realizadas intencionalmente por gates quânticos, bem
como erros, e também veremos em breve que operações de Pauli podem descrever medições. Às vezes também é útil
pensar sobre operações de Pauli como geradores de certos conjuntos num sentido algébrico que você pode reconhecer
se estiver familiarizado com teoria de grupos. Se não estás familiarizado com teoria de grupos, tudo bem, não é realmente essencial
para esta lição, mas se estiveres interessado em estudar correção de erros quânticos com maior profundidade, você pode achar que alguma
teoria de grupos básica é muito útil para isso. De qualquer forma, vamos supor que P1 até PR são operações de Pauli de N qubits,
portanto P1 é uma operação de Pauli de N qubits, P2 é uma operação de Pauli de N qubits, e assim por diante. Quando nos referimos ao conjunto gerado por
P1 até PR, o que queremos dizer é o conjunto de todas as matrizes que podemos obter multiplicando essas matrizes juntas em
qualquer combinação e em qualquer ordem que escolhermos, tomando cada uma quantas vezes quisermos. Veremos alguns exemplos em apenas
um momento, mas primeiro deixa-me mencionar a notação que usamos para denotar esse conjunto. O conjunto gerado por P1 até PR é
P1 até PR separados por vírgulas dentro de colchetes angulares. Parece que poderíamos facilmente confundir
essa notação com notação de produto interno, mas isso geralmente não acontece e essa é a notação tradicional em teoria de
grupos. Aqui está um exemplo do conjunto gerado por X, Y e Z, então N é igual a um neste exemplo porque não há
produtos tensoriais e estamos tomando todas as três matrizes de Pauli não-identidade como geradores. Acontece que há
16 matrizes que podem ser geradas formando produtos que incluem essas três matrizes, e você pode raciocinar sobre isso
através das regras de multiplicação que vimos anteriormente. Especificamente, podemos é claro obter X, Y e Z, bem como a identidade,
e na verdade também podemos obter qualquer uma dessas quatro matrizes vezes I, 1 ou menos I, e é
isso. Esse conjunto é comumente conhecido como o grupo de Pauli. Poderíamos também considerar o conjunto
gerado apenas por X e Z, e acabamos obtendo metade do grupo de Pauli nesse caso.
E um último exemplo, pelo menos por agora: podemos considerar o conjunto gerado por X tensorial X e Z tensorial Z, então N é igual a
dois neste caso, e acabamos obtendo apenas quatro elementos desta vez, devido ao fato de que X tensorial X e Z tensorial Z
comutam entre si. Matrizes de Pauli e operações de Pauli de N qubits de forma mais geral descrevem
operações unitárias, sejam erros ou intencionais, mas também descrevem
medições. Para ser mais preciso, começando apenas com as três matrizes de Pauli não-identidade, podemos associar cada uma dessas
matrizes com uma medição projetiva definida em termos de seus autovalores e autovetores, e aqui na tela temos
decomposições espectrais dessas matrizes que vão ajudar a esclarecer isso. Em essência, quando nos referimos a uma medição X,
uma medição Y ou uma medição Z, queremos dizer a medição projetiva definida pelas projeções
nos autoespaços dessas matrizes, e comumente pensamos nos autovalores como sendo os correspondentes
resultados da medição. Por exemplo, uma medição X é uma medição em relação à base mais/menos
de um qubit, ou alternativamente podemos descrevê-la pelo conjunto contendo as projeções ket plus bra plus e ket
minus bra minus. Uma medição Z por outro lado nada mais é do que uma medição na base padrão,
embora como eu disse, às vezes identificamos os autovalores com os resultados da medição, e se fizermos isso,
os resultados são mais um e menos um, em vez de 0 e 1, respectivamente. Podemos de fato fazer algo
nessa linha para matrizes hermitianas arbitrárias, e o termo observável é comumente usado nessa situação. Para matrizes de
Pauli e operações de Pauli de N qubits de forma mais geral, podemos realizar tais medições de forma não-destrutiva usando
estimação de fase, e só para ter certeza de que esse diagrama está claro: aqui estamos realizando as medições de forma não-destrutiva no
qubit superior, enquanto o qubit inferior é sempre inicializado no estado mais, ou em outras palavras, com um Hadamard aplicado a um
estado zero, porque é assim que a estimação de fase funciona. Note que como os autovalores
são apenas mais um e menos um neste caso, só precisamos de um qubit de controle, que é o qubit inferior neste
diagrama. Mais do que isso seria apenas um desperdício, porque há apenas um bit de precisão com o qual se preocupar. O autovalor
é mais um ou menos um e a medição já é perfeita assim. O resultado desta medição, pelo
modo, ou seja, a medição na base padrão no circuit, será zero para o resultado de autovalor mais um,
que corresponde ao estado mais no caso de um observável X, e o resultado é um para o autovalor menos um
ou o estado menos neste caso. Tudo o que acabei de dizer se estende naturalmente a operações de Pauli de N qubits,
desde que tenhamos em mente que quando pensamos sobre um observável, estamos falando sobre medir os autovalores,
não medir em relação a uma base de autovetores. Por exemplo, considere a operação de Pauli de dois
qubits Z tensorial Z. Mais uma vez, há dois autovalores, mais um e menos um, então a
medição é descrita por duas projeções. Note em particular que a medição que associamos com
esse observável não é o mesmo que medir ambos os qubits com uma medição Z, ou em outras palavras uma medição na base padrão, mas sim é uma medição projetiva de dois
resultados onde as projeções são sobre os espaços gerados por todos os autovetores correspondentes a
cada um dos dois autovalores, mais um e menos um. Outra forma de pensar sobre isso é que os autovalores de um produto
tensorial são produtos dos autovalores das matrizes individuais cujo produto tensorial estamos tomando, e
como negativo 1 * negativo 1 é o mesmo que positivo 1 * positivo 1, por exemplo, essa medição não
distingue entre 00 e 11. Portanto, se fôssemos medir, digamos, um estado Bell phi mais com a medição
descrita por esse observável, teríamos certeza de obter o resultado correspondente ao autovalor mais um,
e o estado ficaria inalterado, em vez de colapsar para 00 ou 11, que é o que aconteceria se
realizássemos as medições na base padrão nos dois qubits. Portanto, uma medição Z tensorial Z não é
a mesma coisa que realizar duas medições Z independentemente, mas podemos de fato realizar medições assim usando estimação de
fase precisamente da mesma forma que antes, usando um único qubit de controle, como é mostrado no diagrama do circuit, que
se generaliza para qualquer operação de Pauli de N qubits no lugar de Z tensorial Z. Quando temos apenas matrizes de Pauli Z,
podemos simplificar o circuit assim, e o que isso revela — o que também é evidente das projeções que definem
a medição — é que realizar uma medição Z tensorial Z em dois qubits é equivalente a medir a paridade deles
pensando em termos da base padrão, e isso se generaliza para o produto tensorial de qualquer número de matrizes de Pauli Z.
A seguir, vamos dar uma segunda olhada no código de repetição de três bits, desta vez formulando-o em termos de operações de
Pauli. Este será nosso primeiro exemplo, bem simples, de um código estabilizador, e discutiremos como generalizar essa
noção em breve, mas é útil ver como funciona neste caso simples primeiro. Lembre-se de que quando aplicamos o
código de repetição de 3 bits a qubits, codificamos um dado estado de qubit Alpha |0⟩ mais beta |1⟩ como Alpha |000⟩ mais beta |111⟩,
e vamos dar a essa codificação de três qubits o nome de psi por conveniência. Portanto, por definição, psi é uma codificação válida de três qubits
de um estado de qubit. Mas se quisermos verificar isso, é suficiente verificar que as duas equações a seguir são verdadeiras. A
primeira equação afirma que aplicar operações Z aos dois qubits mais à esquerda de psi não faz nada com psi, o que é dizer que
psi é um autovetor de Z tensorial Z tensorial Identidade, ou apenas ZZ identidade de forma abreviada, com autovalor um. E a segunda
equação é similar, exceto que as operações Z são aplicadas aos dois qubits mais à direita. A ideia é: se pensarmos em psi
como uma combinação linear de estados da base padrão, então a primeira equação implica que só podemos ter coeficientes não-nulos para estados da base padrão
onde os dois bits mais à esquerda têm paridade par, ou equivalentemente são iguais, e a segunda equação implica que só podemos
ter coeficientes não-nulos para estados da base padrão para os quais os dois bits mais à direita têm paridade par. Outra forma de pensar sobre isso
é ver essas duas operações de Pauli como observáveis, e se fôssemos medir esses dois observáveis usando o
circuit simplificado que mencionei há pouco, teríamos certeza de obter um resultado de medição correspondente aos autovalores mais um,
porque psi é um autovetor de ambos os observáveis com autovalor um. Mas esta versão simplificada do circuit combinado
para medir os observáveis independentemente nada mais é do que nosso circuit de verificação de paridade para o código de repetição de 3 bits,
e assim vemos que nossas duas equações juntas são equivalentes ao circuit de verificação de paridade produzindo 00,
que é a síndrome que indica que nenhum erro foi detectado. As operações de Pauli de três qubits
ZZ identidade e identidade ZZ são chamadas de geradores estabilizadores para este código, e o estabilizador do código é o conjunto
gerado pelos geradores estabilizadores. Esse conjunto, o estabilizador, é um objeto matemático fundamentalmente importante
associado a este código, e discutiremos mais adiante o papel que ele desempenha conforme a lição continua. Por ora,
vou apenas apontar que poderíamos ter feito uma escolha diferente para os geradores. Por exemplo, poderíamos ter selecionado Z identidade Z no lugar de qualquer um
dos geradores que selecionamos, e o código e o estabilizador seriam exatamente os mesmos. A seguir, consideraremos a detecção de bit flip
para o código de repetição de três bits, com foco nas interações e relacionamentos entre as operações de
Pauli envolvidas, ou seja, os geradores estabilizadores e os próprios erros. Suponha que codificamos um
qubit usando o código de repetição de três bits e um erro de bit flip ocorre no qubit mais à esquerda. Isso faz com que nosso estado psi seja
transformado de acordo com a ação de uma operação X, ou erro X, no qubit mais à esquerda. Como já sabemos, podemos detectar
esse erro realizando as verificações de paridade para o código de repetição de três bits, ou equivalentemente podemos medir
a codificação de forma não-destrutiva, tratando os geradores estabilizadores como observáveis. Vamos começar com o primeiro
gerador estabilizador e ver o que acontece. Nosso estado foi afetado por um erro X e gostaríamos de entender
como a medição do gerador estabilizador como um observável é influenciada por esse erro. X e Z anticomutam, enquanto
tudo comuta com a matriz identidade, e portanto segue-se que ZZ identidade anticomuta com X identidade
identidade. Portanto, obtemos um sinal de menos quando a ordem é trocada, e também sabemos que ZZ identidade não faz nada com psi
porque psi é uma codificação válida de um qubit, e codificações válidas são sempre autovetores de mais um de ambos os geradores
estabilizadores. Isso nos deixa com X identidade identidade negativo aplicado a psi, e portanto X identidade identidade aplicado a
psi é um autovetor de ZZ identidade com autovalor negativo um. Também podemos fazer algo semelhante
com o segundo gerador estabilizador, mas desta vez o erro comuta com o gerador estabilizador, e portanto nosso
estado corrompido é novamente um autovetor do gerador estabilizador, mas desta vez o autovalor é positivo
um. Então nosso estado corrompido é um autovetor de ambos os geradores estabilizadores, e se o autovalor é mais um ou
menos um é determinado por se o erro comuta ou anticomuta com cada gerador estabilizador. Para o primeiro,
o erro e o gerador estabilizador anticomutam, e para o segundo eles comutam, e sempre vai ser um ou o outro porque quaisquer dois
operações de Pauli ou comutam ou anticomutam. Enquanto isso, o estado psi em si não desempenha um papel importante
aqui, exceto pelo fato de que os geradores estabilizadores agem trivialmente nesse estado. Então, quando estamos pensando sobre a
detecção de erros, realmente não precisamos nos preocupar com o estado codificado específico. Tudo o que importa é se o erro comuta ou anticomuta
com cada gerador estabilizador. Então, vamos fazer uma tabela que tenha uma linha para cada gerador estabilizador
e uma coluna para cada erro. Aqui, incluí apenas os erros correspondentes a um único bit flip, bem
como nenhum erro, que é indicado pela identidade aplicada em produto tensorial consigo mesma três vezes. Poderíamos adicionar mais colunas para outros erros se quisermos,
mas por ora vamos focar apenas nesses erros. A entrada na tabela é mais um ou menos um dependendo de
se o erro e o gerador estabilizador comutam ou anticomutam. Então para cada erro na tabela podemos olhar
a coluna correspondente para ver como esse erro vai transformar qualquer codificação em um autovetor de mais um ou menos um
de cada gerador estabilizador. Essas colunas correspondem precisamente à síndrome que obteríamos das
verificações de paridade, que são equivalentes às medições não-destrutivas dos geradores estabilizadores como
observáveis. Claro, as entradas nesta tabela são mais uns e menos uns em vez de zeros e uns respectivamente,
e se preferires, podes pensar nas síndromes como sendo as cadeias binárias correspondentes em vez de colunas de mais uns e menos uns, mas há uma
correspondência direta. E só para tornar a conexão entre as síndromes e os autovalores mais clara e direta,
vou me referir a esses vetores de mais uns e menos uns como síndromes, como antes. As síndromes nos dizem
algo sobre qualquer erro que ocorreu, e em particular, se sabemos que um desses quatro possíveis erros
ocorreu, a síndrome nos indica qual foi, e podemos corrigi-lo aplicando o erro novamente, se
escolhermos. A seguir, vou dizer apenas um pouco mais sobre as síndromes e em particular vamos dar uma olhada mais de perto em
seus aspectos algébricos. Nossas codificações são estados de três qubits, portanto são vetores unitários em um
espaço vetorial complexo de oito dimensões, e o que as quatro possíveis síndromes fazem é fatiar esse espaço de oito dimensões
em quatro subespaços bidimensionais, o que significa que os vetores em qualquer um desses subespaços sempre nos darão a mesma
síndrome. Em mais detalhes, este diagrama ilustra como o espaço de oito dimensões é dividido.
Cada gerador estabilizador divide o espaço em dois subespaços de igual dimensão, ou seja, o espaço dos autovetores de mais um
e o espaço dos autovetores de menos um. Por exemplo, os autovetores de mais um de ZZ identidade são combinações lineares
de estados da base padrão para os quais os dois bits mais à esquerda têm paridade par, e os autovetores de menos um são combinações
lineares de estados da base padrão para os quais os dois bits mais à esquerda têm paridade ímpar. E a situação é similar para
o outro gerador estabilizador, exceto que são os dois bits mais à direita em vez dos dois mais à esquerda. Portanto, esses quatro subespaços são fáceis de
descrever neste caso, em virtude do fato de que este é um código muito simples. Em particular, o subespaço
correspondente à síndrome mais um, mais um é o espaço gerado por |000⟩ e |111⟩, que é o espaço de
codificações válidas, e isso é chamado de espaço do código. Em geral, os espaços são gerados pelos estados da base padrão
que são mostrados nos quadrados correspondentes, embora não seja necessariamente tão claro ou fácil de ver. As síndromes
também particionam todas as operações de Pauli de três qubits, que representam os possíveis erros de Pauli que poderiam ocorrer, em quatro coleções de tamanhos iguais
dependendo de qual síndrome esse erro causaria. Por exemplo, qualquer operação de Pauli
que comuta com ambos os geradores estabilizadores resulta na síndrome mais 1, mais 1. E entre as 64 possíveis operações de Pauli de três
qubits, há exatamente 16 delas nesta categoria, incluindo as três mencionadas na tela, e da mesma forma para as outras três
síndromes. Isso não é óbvio, mas é verdade, e essa propriedade básica de que as síndromes particionam tanto o espaço de estados
no qual as codificações vivem quanto todos os possíveis erros de Pauli no espaço em pedaços de tamanhos iguais é algo que
é verdadeiro em geral para códigos estabilizadores, que em breve vamos definir precisamente. Embora seja principalmente um aparte,
vale mencionar que operações de Pauli que comutam com ambos os geradores estabilizadores, ou equivalentemente
operações de Pauli que resultam na síndrome mais 1, mais 1 mas elas mesmas não são proporcionais a elementos do estabilizador, resultam em se comportar como
operações de Pauli de um único qubit no qubit lógico que codificamos. Por exemplo, XXX comuta com
ambos os geradores estabilizadores, mas não é proporcional a nenhum elemento do estabilizador, e de fato é claro,
se você pensar sobre esse código por um momento, que o efeito que essa operação tem em uma codificação é equivalente a um gate X no
qubit lógico que foi codificado. E novamente, isso é algo que se generaliza para todos os códigos estabilizadores. Agora é hora de definir códigos estabilizadores
em geral, e a forma como funciona é que fazemos algo completamente análogo ao que acabamos de discutir para
o código de repetição de três bits, exceto que escolhemos geradores estabilizadores diferentes, que chamaremos de P1
até PR para fins desta explicação. Esses geradores estabilizadores devem todos ser operações de Pauli de N qubits,
onde N é o número de qubits usados para a codificação, e não podemos simplesmente escolher qualquer conjunto de geradores estabilizadores — eles
têm que satisfazer algumas condições básicas. Primeiro, os geradores estabilizadores devem TODOS comutar entre
si. No caso do código de repetição de três bits, não nos demos ao trabalho de notar isso, mas é direto observar que ZZ identidade e identidade
ZZ de fato comutam porque Z comuta consigo mesmo e tudo comuta com a
identidade. Para códigos estabilizadores com geradores estabilizadores mais complicados, por outro lado, incluindo códigos onde temos
tanto Xs quanto Zs aparecendo nos geradores estabilizadores, essa é uma condição importante que precisa ser
verificada. Uma forma de pensar sobre a necessidade dessa condição é que vamos tratar os geradores estabilizadores como observáveis, e ao exigir que
todos comutam, estamos garantindo que a ordem em que realizamos essas medições não
importa. Segundo, os geradores estabilizadores devem formar um chamado conjunto gerador mínimo, o que significa que se removêssemos qualquer
um deles, obteríamos um estabilizador menor, e uma forma de expressar isso matematicamente é mostrada aqui na
tela. Estritamente falando, essa condição não é realmente essencial para a forma como um código estabilizador funciona num sentido operacional,
e às vezes faz sentido pensar sobre conjuntos geradores não-mínimos, como veremos na próxima lição. Mas
para fins de analisar códigos estabilizadores e explicar suas propriedades, vamos assumir que essa condição está em
vigor. Basicamente, essa condição garante que cada observável que medimos para obter a síndrome está
adicionando informação sobre possíveis erros, em vez de ser redundante e fornecer resultados que poderiam ser facilmente inferidos dos outros geradores estabilizadores como
observáveis. E finalmente, deve ser o caso de que pelo menos um vetor não-nulo seja fixado por todos
os geradores estabilizadores, e isso acaba sendo equivalente a exigir que -1 vezes a identidade em N qubits não esteja
contido no estabilizador. Isso não é óbvio, mas o ponto é que é possível escolher um conjunto gerador mínimo
de operações de Pauli de N qubits que todas comutam entre si e ainda assim nenhum vetor é simultaneamente um autovetor de mais um
de todas elas, e não queremos nos preocupar com essa possibilidade porque códigos onde não há codificações válidas não são
interessantes. Então esses são os requisitos sobre os geradores estabilizadores para um código estabilizador, e se tivermos um conjunto de geradores que
satisfaça essas condições, então temos um código estabilizador válido e podemos considerar suas propriedades. Há muitos
diferentes códigos estabilizadores com várias propriedades que os tornam interessantes ou não, mas todos satisfazem certas propriedades básicas
que são reminiscentes das que já observamos para o código de repetição de três bits.
Vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos em breve, mas antes disso, deixa-me mencionar que quando nos referimos ao espaço do código de um código estabilizador, queremos dizer o subespaço
do espaço de estados de N qubits que inclui todo vetor que é simultaneamente um autovetor de mais um de todos os
geradores estabilizadores. Esse é o subespaço do espaço de estados de N qubits no qual as codificações válidas vivem, e teremos mais a
dizer sobre esse subespaço conforme a lição continua. Agora vamos dar uma olhada em alguns exemplos de códigos
estabilizadores. Aqui está o exemplo que já discutimos, o código de repetição de 3 bits comum, e também podemos expressar a
versão modificada desse código da lição anterior, que pode detectar um phase flip em vez de um bit flip, como um código estabilizador, como é mostrado
aqui. Desta vez, os geradores estabilizadores medem observáveis XX em vez de ZZ, então esses são basicamente
verificações de paridade na base mais/menos em vez da base padrão. Em ambos os casos, podemos
ver imediatamente que temos um código estabilizador válido porque os geradores estabilizadores comutam, esses são conjuntos
geradores mínimos, e o espaço do código é não-trivial, como já sabemos. Mas também podemos ver com bastante clareza que não
podemos gerar menos 1 vezes a identidade. E aqui está o código Shore de 9 qubits, que também é um código estabilizador
expresso por geradores estabilizadores. Nesse caso, basicamente temos três cópias do código de repetição de três
bits, uma para cada um dos três blocos de três qubits, bem como os últimos dois geradores estabilizadores que
assumem uma forma que é reminiscente do circuit que vimos na lição anterior para detectar phase flips para este
código. Outra forma de pensar sobre esses dois últimos geradores estabilizadores é que eles assumem exatamente a mesma forma que
temos para o código de repetição de três bits para phase flips, exceto que substituímos XXX por X, e a razão para
isso é que XXX corresponde a uma operação X no qubit lógico codificado usando o código de repetição de 3 bits. Mas
isso é um aparte e não é algo para se preocupar agora. Caso não esteja claro, a seguir vamos dar uma olhada em alguns
mais exemplos, mas antes disso, deixa-me mencionar que as pessoas muitas vezes omitem os símbolos do produto tensorial ao descrever códigos estabilizadores porque tende a
torná-los mais fáceis de ler. Então aqui está como esses códigos ficam sem os símbolos do produto tensorial,
mas é claro que esses são produtos tensoriais e não produtos de matrizes comuns. Por exemplo, estamos apenas omitindo os símbolos do produto tensorial para que fique menos
confuso e os padrões fiquem mais claros. Aqui está outro exemplo, chamado de
código Steane de 7 qubits, e tem algumas características bastante notáveis. Vamos voltar a este
de vez em quando ao longo das lições restantes da unidade, mas por ora podemos simplesmente verificar que é um código estabilizador válido.
Em particular, os três primeiros geradores estabilizadores claramente comutam entre si porque Z comuta com
si mesmo e a identidade comuta com tudo, e a situação é similar para os três últimos, então resta
verificar que se pegarmos um dos geradores Z estabilizadores e um dos geradores X estabilizadores, eles comutam.
E é fácil o suficiente percorrer os nove possíveis emparelhamentos para verificar que em todos esses casos sempre
teremos um X e um Z coincidindo na mesma posição um número par de vezes, então os dois geradores vão comutar, assim
como XX e ZZ comutam. É um conjunto gerador mínimo e tem um espaço de código não-trivial, mas
não vou tentar argumentar isso neste vídeo e em vez disso vou deixar para você pensar, se desejar. O código Steane de 7 qubits é semelhante
ao código Shore de 9 qubits no sentido de que codifica um único qubit e permite a correção de um erro arbitrário em um qubit, mas requer apenas
sete qubits em vez de nove. Esse não é o menor número de qubits necessário para que um código de correção de erros
codifique um qubit e corrija um erro arbitrário em um único qubit. Aqui está um código estabilizador que é
normalmente chamado apenas de código de 5 qubits, que também codifica um único qubit e pode corrigir qualquer erro em um único qubit,
e cinco é o menor número de qubits para o qual isso é possível. Aqui está outro exemplo de um
código estabilizador, embora não seja realmente um código propriamente dito no sentido de que o espaço do código é
unidimensional. Em particular, o espaço do código para este código é o espaço gerado por um ebit, ou em outras palavras, um estado Bell phi mais.
Portanto, você não pode realmente codificar nenhum qubit usando este código, mas ainda é um código estabilizador válido onde o espaço do
código é unidimensional. E é possível fazer algo semelhante para um estado
GHZ. Então esses são alguns exemplos de códigos estabilizadores, e veremos infinitamente mais exemplos na
próxima lição. Suponha que recebemos um código estabilizador. Uma pergunta natural a fazer sobre ele
— talvez a primeira pergunta que venha à mente — é: quantos qubits ele codifica? Essa pergunta tem uma resposta muito simples,
e para explicá-la vamos ser precisos sobre o código estabilizador em consideração. Temos R geradores estabilizadores de N qubits
P1 até PR que satisfazem os três requisitos que mencionei anteriormente, a saber, que os
geradores estabilizadores todos comutam entre si, este é um conjunto gerador mínimo para que não obteríamos o mesmo
estabilizador se removêssemos um dos geradores, e há pelo menos um vetor não-nulo no espaço do
código. Como o teorema mostrado na tela indica, deve então ser que o espaço do código do código estabilizador tem
dimensão 2 elevado a N menos R, ou outra forma de dizer isso é que podemos codificar N
menos R qubits usando este código. Intuitivamente falando, temos N qubits em nossas codificações e cada
gerador estabilizador efetivamente retira um qubit em termos de quantos qubits podemos codificar.
Esse teorema não é muito difícil de provar e vou te mostrar uma prova em apenas um momento, mas primeiro vamos dar uma olhada em apenas
alguns exemplos. Começando com o código de repetição de 3 bits comum, temos três qubits em nossas
codificações, então N é igual a três, e há R igual a 2 geradores estabilizadores, e portanto podemos codificar um
qubit usando este código. Note que isso não é sobre quais ou quantos erros podem ser detectados ou
corrigidos, isso é outro assunto. Esta é apenas uma afirmação sobre a dimensão do espaço do código.
Para outro exemplo, considere o código de 5 qubits. Aqui temos cinco qubits e quatro
geradores estabilizadores, portanto mais uma vez o espaço do código tem dimensão dois, o que significa que podemos codificar um qubit usando este
código. E mais um exemplo por agora: para o código estabilizador de ebit, temos dois qubits e dois geradores estabilizadores, então
o espaço do código é unidimensional, e como mencionei anteriormente, é o espaço gerado pelo estado Bell phi mais.
Veremos mais exemplos conforme continuamos, incluindo códigos onde podemos codificar mais de um qubit, mas por ora vamos
ver como podemos provar o teorema. A primeira coisa que precisamos observar é que, como os geradores
estabilizadores comutam e formam um conjunto gerador mínimo, e porque toda operação de Pauli é sua própria inversa, todo
elemento no estabilizador pode ser expresso de forma única como um produto onde elevamos cada gerador estabilizador
PK à potência AK, onde cada AK é zero ou um, e então multiplicamos os resultados
juntos. Outra forma de dizer isso é que obtemos cada elemento do estabilizador multiplicando juntos algum subconjunto dos
geradores estabilizadores, e nunca obtemos o mesmo elemento estabilizador de diferentes subconjuntos. E uma coisa que
isso implica é que a única forma de expressar a operação de identidade de N qubits dessa maneira é tomar todas as potências iguais a
zero. A seguir, vamos definir pi K como a projeção no autoespaço de mais um de PK para cada K de 1 a R, e há
uma fórmula simples para essa projeção: podemos simplesmente fazer a média de PK com a identidade em N qubits, o que efetivamente deixa os
autovalores de mais um intactos e desloca todos os autovalores de menos um para zero.
Agora o espaço do código é definido como o conjunto de todos os vetores que são simultaneamente autovetores de mais um de todos
os geradores estabilizadores. Dado que os geradores estabilizadores comutam, as projeções também devem comutar, e isso
implica que o produto dessas projeções também é uma projeção, e em particular é a projeção sobre
a interseção dos subespaços sobre os quais as projeções individuais projetam, ou em outras palavras é a projeção sobre
o espaço do código. Podemos expandir esse produto e o que obtemos é a média sobre cada
elemento do estabilizador. E finalmente, porque a dimensão de qualquer subespaço é igual a
o traço da projeção sobre esse subespaço, descobrimos que a dimensão do espaço do código é a média dos traços sobre os elementos do
estabilizador. Mas com exceção da operação de identidade de N qubits, todos os elementos do estabilizador devem ter
traço igual a zero, porque as três matrizes de Pauli não-identidade todas têm traço igual a zero. O traço da
operação de identidade de N qubits é 2 elevado a N, e portanto descobrimos que a dimensão do espaço do código é 2 elevado a N menos R, o que prova o
teorema. A seguir, vou dizer apenas um pouco sobre como qubits podem ser codificados usando códigos estabilizadores, mas para fazer isso precisamos primeiro
introduzir operações Clifford. Operações Clifford são operações unitárias em qualquer número de
qubits que podem ser implementadas por circuits quânticos com um conjunto restrito de gates, nomeadamente gates Hadamard, gates S
e gates CNOT. Note que gates T não estão incluídos, nem gates Toffoli ou gates Fredkin,
e não só esses gates não estão incluídos nesta lista, mas na verdade não é possível implementar esses gates
usando os listados aqui, portanto eles não são operações Clifford. Operações de Pauli por outro lado
são operações Clifford, e especificamente podem ser implementadas usando sequências de gates Hadamard e S.
Portanto, essa é uma forma simples de definir operações Clifford, mas não explica realmente por que são definidas assim
ou o que é especial sobre essa coleção específica de gates. Aqui está a razão real pela qual as operações Clifford são definidas dessa
forma. A menos de uma fase global, as operações Clifford de N qubits são precisamente as operações
unitárias que sempre transformam operações de Pauli em operações de Pauli por conjugação. Para ser mais preciso, uma operação
unitária de N bits U é uma operação Clifford a menos de um fator de fase global se e somente se para toda operação de Pauli de N qubits,
conjugar essa operação de Pauli por U nos dá mais ou menos um vezes alguma operação de N qubits
possivelmente diferente. Você pode verificar facilmente que essa propriedade é verdadeira para gates Hadamard, gates S
e gates CNOT, então necessariamente vale para circuits construídos a partir desses gates. O que é mais difícil de provar é que
vale na outra direção, ou seja, que se nos for dada uma operação unitária de N bits U particular que satisfaz essa
propriedade, então deve ser possível implementá-la a menos de uma fase global usando apenas gates Hadamard, S e CNOT.
Não vou apresentar a prova dessa implicação, mas é verdade e você pode consultá-la se estiver
interessado. Operações Clifford não são universais para computação quântica, o que significa que não podemos executar computações quânticas arbitrárias
usando apenas gates Hadamard, S e CNOT. Na verdade, para um dado valor de N, há apenas um número finito de
operações Clifford de N qubits, então é um conjunto discreto de operações. Portanto, ao contrário de um
conjunto universal de gates quânticos, não podemos aproximar operações unitárias arbitrárias a qualquer nível desejado de precisão, e
na verdade, realizar operações Clifford em estados da base padrão seguidas de medições na base padrão não pode nos permitir
realizar computações que estejam fora do alcance de algoritmos clássicos, porque podemos simular eficientemente computações desta forma
classicamente. Esse fato é conhecido como o teorema de Gottesman-Knill, e a prova padrão desse teorema é em certo sentido
baseada no formalismo estabilizador. Em particular, a forma como funciona é que podemos acompanhar como as operações Clifford transformam as operações de
Pauli por conjugação, o que pode ser feito eficientemente, e então inferir a partir disso o que as computações fazem com
os qubits. Então o que isso tem a ver com códigos estabilizadores? Bem, um código estabilizador nos fornece
um espaço de código de uma certa dimensão e temos a liberdade de usar esse espaço de código como quisermos, portanto nada nos força a codificar
qubits nesse espaço de uma forma específica, mas sempre será possível realizar uma codificação usando uma operação Clifford
como codificador. Isso é bom porque operações Clifford são relativamente simples em comparação com operações unitárias arbitrárias.
Há formas de otimizar sua implementação que funcionam de maneira semelhante à prova do teorema de Gottesman-
Knill, e como resultado, circuits para implementá-las nunca precisam ser muito
grandes. Em particular, sempre podemos realizar uma codificação usando uma operação Clifford que requer um pouco menos de um número quadrático de gates,
porque isso é de fato verdade para toda operação Clifford. Portanto, o resultado final é que para um dado código estabilizador, sempre é
possível codificar qubits eficientemente usando esse código, e as ferramentas matemáticas que são úteis para entender operações Clifford podem ajudar com esse
processo. Por exemplo, aqui está um codificador para o código Steane de 7 qubits. É uma operação Clifford e acontece que
este sequer precisa de gates S. Para códigos estabilizadores gerais, a detecção de erros funciona da seguinte
maneira. Como antes, vamos assumir que temos geradores estabilizadores de N qubits P1 até PR, e vamos deixar E ser uma operação de
Pauli de N qubits representando um erro hipotético em uma codificação. Estamos considerando apenas
operações de Pauli como erros, a propósito, porque a discretização de erros funciona da mesma forma para códigos estabilizadores arbitrários como acontece para o código Shore de 9 qubits.
A forma como verificamos erros é medir cada um dos geradores estabilizadores como
observáveis. Há R geradores estabilizadores, então isso significa R resultados onde cada um é mais um ou menos um
ou um valor binário se preferires associar zero a mais um e um a menos um, e esses R resultados
juntos formam a síndrome, assim como tínhamos para o código de repetição de três bits quando R era igual a
dois. Em geral, há três casos possíveis para o erro E em termos de sua detecção, e eles são os seguintes. Primeiro,
poderia ser que E esteja no estabilizador, o que significa que é possível gerar E a partir dos geradores estabilizadores, ou
de forma um pouco mais geral, poderia ser que E seja equivalente a um elemento estabilizador a menos de uma fase
global. Nesse caso, E não é realmente um erro de forma alguma, porque não tem efeito no espaço do código além de possivelmente
injetar uma fase global, que não tem nenhum efeito. Portanto, não precisamos nos preocupar com erros como este de forma alguma. Qualquer
ação não-trivial que possa ter acontece fora do espaço do código, então não nos diz respeito.
Muito mais preocupante é a possibilidade de que E não esteja no estabilizador mesmo a menos de uma fase global, mas
mesmo assim comute com todos e cada um dos nossos geradores estabilizadores. Lembre-se de que é a
anticomutação do erro com um gerador estabilizador que causa um menos um aparecer em algum lugar na síndrome,
mas isso não acontece nesse caso. Então este é um erro que de fato muda vetores no espaço do código de alguma
forma não-trivial, e sabemos isso porque do contrário seria proporcional a um elemento estabilizador, mas passa
despercebido pelo código. Portanto, este é o caso ruim: temos um erro que pode estar potencialmente mudando
qualquer informação quântica que codificamos, mas o código é alheio a esse fato. Por exemplo, para o código de repetição de três bits,
XXX se enquadra nessa categoria. E a última possibilidade é que E
anticomute com pelo menos um dos geradores estabilizadores, e isso significa que o código detecta esse erro porque
obteremos uma síndrome com pelo menos um menos um em algum lugar, o que indica que algo está errado e precisaremos tentar corrigir esse erro
de alguma forma. Então essas são as possibilidades. Como ponto de terminologia,
quando nos referimos à distância de um código estabilizador, o que queremos dizer é o peso mínimo de uma operação de Pauli que se enquadra
na segunda categoria, o que significa que muda o espaço do código de alguma forma não-trivial mas o código não
detecta isso. E quando dizemos que um código estabilizador é um código estabilizador [[n,m,d]] usando
colchetes duplos como é mostrado na tela, o que isso significa é que as codificações têm comprimento de N qubits, o
código é capaz de codificar M qubits, de modo que o espaço do código tem dimensão 2 elevado a M, e sua distância é D. Portanto, um erro precisa ter
peso D ou mais para mudar o estado lógico de qualquer qubit que codificamos sem ser detectado como um
erro. Agora vamos dar uma olhada no código Steane de 7 qubits como exemplo e determinar qual é sua distância.
Aqui estão os geradores estabilizadores para este código, e lembre-se de que a distância é o peso mínimo de uma
operação de Pauli de N qubits que comuta com todos os geradores estabilizadores mas ela mesma não está no estabilizador, nem
é proporcional a um elemento do estabilizador. O que vamos determinar é que este código tem distância
três. A forma como vamos determinar isso é primeiro considerar qualquer operação de Pauli tendo peso no máximo dois, e vamos
concluir que a única forma como ela pode comutar com todos os seis geradores estabilizadores é ser a identidade, que é sempre um elemento do
estabilizador. Então vamos supor que as matrizes de Pauli possivelmente não-identidade que formam essa operação, que chamaremos de
P e Q, aparecem nas duas posições mais à esquerda. Esse é apenas um caso e precisamos de fato
considerar todos os outros possíveis locais para essas matrizes de Pauli possivelmente não-identidade, mas o argumento é basicamente o mesmo para todas
as possíveis localizações. Bem, por hipótese essa operação comuta com todos os seis
geradores estabilizadores, então em particular comuta com este e também comuta com este.
Q alinha com a matriz identidade em ambos esses geradores, e é por isso que escolhemos esses dois, e temos matrizes
identidade nas cinco posições mais à direita deste erro, e portanto concluímos que P deve comutar com X
e Z, porque do contrário esse erro anticomutaria com um desses dois geradores. Mas a única matriz de Pauli que
comuta com X e Z é a identidade, então P deve ser a identidade. E agora que sabemos disso,
podemos escolher dois geradores estabilizadores que têm um X e um Z na segunda posição a partir da esquerda, e podemos
tirar uma conclusão semelhante sobre Q. Portanto, não há como um erro de peso no máximo 2 passar despercebido por este código
a menos que seja apenas a operação identidade, que está no estabilizador — portanto isso não é realmente
um erro. Por outro lado, há operações de Pauli de peso três que comutam com todos os seis desses geradores estabilizadores
mas não são proporcionais a elementos estabilizadores, e aqui estão dois exemplos. Portanto, concluímos que este
código tem distância três. A última coisa que vamos discutir nesta lição é a correção de erros para
códigos estabilizadores. Como de costume, vamos assumir que nosso código é especificado por geradores estabilizadores de N qubits
P1 até PR, e vamos começar pensando um pouco sobre todos os possíveis erros que poderiam
ocorrer. Há 2 elevado a R possíveis síndromes, e como mencionei anteriormente na lição, essas síndromes particionam todas
as possíveis operações de Pauli de N qubits em coleções de tamanhos iguais, o que significa 4 elevado a N dividido por 2 elevado a R operações de Pauli
em cada conjunto. Então quando vemos uma síndrome particular, poderia ser que qualquer um desses 4 elevado a N dividido por 2
elevado a R erros seja responsável. Estamos supercontando um pouco aqui, porém, porque alguns desses
erros têm exatamente o mesmo efeito no espaço do código. Em particular, se temos um erro E e multiplicamos E por qualquer
elemento estabilizador S, então vamos obter outro erro que tem exatamente o mesmo efeito no espaço do código que E. Portanto
esses são erros equivalentes. O estabilizador tem 2 elevado a R elementos, e se levarmos isso em conta, encontramos
que para cada síndrome há 4 elevado a N menos R classes de equivalência de erros que poderiam ter causado aquela
síndrome. E o que isso significa é que a menos que R seja igual a N, caso em que temos um espaço de código unidimensional e
portanto não podemos codificar nenhum qubit, não vai ser possível corrigir todos os erros que podemos detectar. Em vez disso,
o que temos que fazer é escolher apenas uma operação de correção para cada síndrome, na esperança de corrigir apenas uma classe de erros
equivalentes. Então como devemos escolher qual correção realizar para cada síndrome? Uma estratégia natural é escolher
a operação de Pauli de menor peso que causa qualquer síndrome que medimos, com a ideia de que operações de Pauli de menor peso
representam explicações mais prováveis para essa síndrome. Isso pode não ser de fato o caso
para alguns modelos de ruído, e outra estratégia natural é de alguma forma calcular o erro mais provável que causa a
síndrome dada. Mas por ora vamos apenas considerar a estratégia onde tentamos corrigir erros selecionando a operação de Pauli de menor peso causando a
síndrome. Para um código estabilizador de distância D, essa estratégia sempre nos permitirá corrigir erros tendo peso estritamente
menor que metade de D, ou em outras palavras, peso no máximo D menos 1 dividido por 2, e explicarei brevemente por que
isso acontece. Isso vai mostrar, por exemplo, que o código Steane de 7 qubits pode corrigir qualquer erro de Pauli de peso um, e pela
discretização de erros isso significa que, assim como o código Shore de 9 qubits, o código Steane pode corrigir um
erro arbitrário em um qubit. Então aqui está como isso funciona. Considere que este círculo representa todas as possíveis operações de Pauli
que resultam na síndrome de todos mais um, que é a síndrome que sugere que nenhum erro ocorreu
e tudo está bem. Entre essas operações, temos elementos do estabilizador, ou realmente
operações que são proporcionais a elementos do estabilizador, e também temos erros não-triviais que mudam o espaço do código de alguma forma mas não são
detectados pelo código. E sabemos pela definição de distância que toda operação de Pauli nessa categoria deve ter peso pelo menos
D, porque D é definido como o peso mínimo dessas operações. Também temos operações de Pauli
que causam outras síndromes e poderíamos considerar cada síndrome por sua vez se desejarmos, mas aqui estamos apenas imaginando
que uma tal síndrome S apareceu. Agora imagine que E é um erro nesta
categoria que tem peso estritamente menor que metade da distância D. Bem, não sabemos que este é
necessariamente a operação de peso mínimo neste círculo, então vamos tomar C como sendo a operação de peso mínimo neste conjunto, ou uma delas em caso de empate.
Portanto, poderia ser que C seja igual a E ou possivelmente não, mas como C tem
peso mínimo, sabemos que não pode ter peso maior do que o peso de E, porque C também está no conjunto
e tem peso mínimo. Portanto, a operação de correção C deve ter peso estritamente menor que metade de
D. Então o que acontece se aplicarmos essa correção C a qualquer que seja o estado que obtemos após o erro E
ocorrer? A resposta é que o estado que obtemos é C * E multiplicado pela codificação original, porque primeiro
multiplicamos por E — esse foi o erro — e então multiplicamos por C para tentar corrigi-lo. E este produto deve estar
no estabilizador ou ser proporcional a um elemento do estabilizador, e eis o porquê. Primeiro, porque E e C nos dão a
mesma síndrome, C * E deve nos dar a síndrome de todos mais um. Isso porque para um dado
gerador estabilizador, ou C e E ambos comutam com esse gerador, ou ambos anticomutam. Tem que ser o mesmo para
ambos porque as síndromes são as mesmas, e se você pensar sobre isso por um momento, isso implica que C * E deve
comutar com todos os geradores estabilizadores. E finalmente, C * E tem que estar
no estabilizador porque seu peso não pode ser maior do que a soma dos pesos de C e E, então seu peso
é estritamente menor que D, e isso significa que corrigimos E com sucesso, porque aplicar E seguido de C não faz nada no
espaço do código. Portanto, isso é ótimo, mas há apenas um problema, e é que para códigos estabilizadores
em geral, é um problema computacionalmente difícil calcular a operação de menor peso causando uma dada
síndrome. E de fato isso é verdade mesmo para códigos clássicos, que neste contexto podemos pensar como códigos estabilizadores
onde temos apenas matrizes identidade e matrizes de Pauli Z aparecendo como fatores tensoriais dentro dos geradores
estabilizadores. Portanto, ao contrário da etapa de codificação, as operações Clifford não vêm ao nosso resgate desta vez, e a única solução razoável
é escolher códigos específicos para os quais boas correções possam ser calculadas eficientemente, e não há receita para
isso. Simplificando, criar códigos estabilizadores assim faz parte da arte
do design de códigos quânticos, e esse é um bom lugar para parar nesta lição. Espero que você se junte a mim
na próxima lição, na qual vamos dar uma olhada em algumas construções específicas de códigos quânticos, incluindo códigos que ilustram a arte do design de códigos quânticos
de uma forma bastante espetacular. Até a próxima!